Tulsi gabbard is a former member of
Congress a former presidential candidate
one of the very few people in the world
who went on television after this
Invasion a year ago and said this could
get really dangerous you were right and
now that China is aligning with Russia
and supporting the Russian war effort
effectively against us this seems like a
massive Turning Point
well you you heard it from zielinski
himself talking about the consequences
of World War III the thing is he has
made very clear that that's where he
thinks we are already that we are in
World War III Ukraine is the tip of the
spear and this is how he justifies
demanding making demands of the United
States and all of these NATO countries
to equip him with all of the weapons and
aircraft and tanks that the United
States and NATO have to go and fight
this war that we are in against Russia
he is doing everything that he can to
bring us and NATO into this war directly
into conflict with Russia you remember
when their Ukrainian defense missile
defense system unfortunately had a
missile that went into Poland and killed
two civilians on a farm what did
zielinski say his very first thing first
person on camera saying hey this is a
direct attack against the NATO Ally U.S
and NATO you must go and attack you must
go and attack Russia the scary thing to
me talk worker is to hear people like
zielinski to hear Democrats and
Republicans in the United States
Congress and Biden Administration
officials speak so calmly and with a
straight face about World War III how
would it be won how would we respond to
the use of tactical nuclear weapons what
are our options in this battlefield
forgetting what Ronald Reagan said when
he said a nuclear war cannot be won and
therefore should never be fought This
World War III this path that we are on
unless we change course it will result
in nuclear war if all of the
nuclear-armed countries in the worlds on
this path towards a head-on collision
I mean let's ask a really quick question
so zielinski who I think this country
has born with great patience actually
for the last year has repeatedly said
I've got a border dispute with my
neighbor Russia you live thousands of
miles away you're not connected but
because of that border dispute and their
invasion of the eastern half of my
country your whole family could die and
I'm okay with that how why aren't
Americans rising up as one and saying
you're suggesting it's okay that my
family dies no it's not okay off the
stage like what why are we putting up
with this honestly you know you look at
the lies that the American people are
being told by President Biden by Mitch
McConnell by these war mongers in both
parties selling this lie that this is
about defending freedom and democracy
and as he said there's no greater threat
to that democracy than this fight
against this war against Russia they are
the ones who are undermining our
democracy they are the ones who are
denying the American people our
constitutional right to have a say
whether or not we go to war or not it is
it is an affront to the Constitution and
every single American and we should all
be raising hell about this because it is
our future the future of the world
that's at stake
I agree I mean how much weed are people
smoking this this is a real issue this
is not one of the fake issues you know
that we there is no more real issue than
this I agree I agree Tulsi gabard thanks
so much for joining us thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight